I’m Ukrainian.
And my country is fighting
a war for survival.
But there is another war
where we all must fight.
Fight for the future of the planet.
It's a war against climate change.
Both of them have dramatic consequences
for the future of our lives.
Both are killing thousands.
And the root cause of both
is overdependence on fossil fuels.
Today, I want to explain
how Ukraine's energy challenge
can help the world
to fight climate change.
For decades,
Russia has been weaponizing energy
to impose control over countries.
It has cut gas supply during the winter,
bribed us with cheap gas,
built pipelines to bypass Ukraine
and under-supply gas
to provoke energy shock
that hurt all of us.
But today,
Russia moved from economic war
to physical destruction
of our infrastructure,
launching missiles to destroy
our power stations and grids
and trying to crush the Ukrainian people.
I get to see the impact every day
running DTEK,
one of the largest Ukrainian
power suppliers.
When I wake up every morning,
my first job is to see
whether we've been hit and how bad.
Since the beginning of this war,
our company was attacked
more than 10,000 times.
A hundred of DTEK employees
have been killed on a military front line
or serving on energy front line behind.
These attacks expose not only
Ukraine's vulnerability, but the world's.
Almost every economy on earth
depends on massive,
highly centralized but easily
targeted energy systems
used to extract and burn fossil fuels.
But now in Ukraine,
the war is teaching something new.
That relying on renewable power,
we create much more resilient
and secure energy system.
To understand why,
picture a wind turbine.
It's big.
700 tons and 130 metres tall.
But actually, the footprint
is just a few meters.
It's hard to be attacked by missiles
and if they succeed one, all other
wind turbines are still running.
This kind of distributed power systems
combined with the energy
from household solar panels,
can massively enhance energy security
of countries all over the world.
And not only during war time,
but against other threats
like fires and floods.
Ukraine is becoming a testing ground
for a new energy future.
After the first invasion in 2014,
Russia destroyed or captured more
than 30 percent of DTEK power assets.
Our response was to double
renewable capacity,
helping Ukraine to become the country
with one of the highest growth rates
of renewables in the world.
One real life example
and symbol of our resilience
is the Tiligulska wind farm
on the coast of the Black Sea,
just 60 miles from the front line.
Through the first 15 months of the war,
we built wind farm
without foreign contractors,
sometimes with missiles
flying above our heads
and spending a lot of time
in bomb shelters.
And we succeeded.
From May 2023, we supply green energy
produced by this wind farm
to more than 200,000 households.
And we are planning
to expand this wind farm
to become one of the largest
in Eastern Europe.
War in Ukraine forced Europe
to end its dependence
on dirty Russian energy
through accelerating green transition.
And Ukraine can play a key role
by becoming a major supplier
of clean energy to Europe.
With the right level
of foreign investments,
Ukraine can build enough
renewable capacity by 2030
to supply Europe
as much clean energy as countries
like Finland produce during the year.
The vision of Ukraine -- greener,
and facing west towards Europe --
is even embraced by thousands
of DTEK coal miners
serving on the front line against Russia.
So when do we launch
this green counteroffensive?
The smart move is not to wait,
but to accelerate
so that we meet
the climate crisis challenge
to establish energy independence
and to build much more
resilient energy systems.
A green transition will help
to win both of these wars
and secure a lasting peace.
(In Ukrainian: Glory to Ukraine).